welcome back to new rock stars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about captain
america's
evolving suit and how the avengers
sneaking in and out of the smithsonian
keeps getting that security guard in
trouble
my name is mt and i'm here today with
the one and the only
eric voss how you doing today eric hey
mt it's good to be back with you that
forced security guard i mean
security there is pretty lax if sam can
drag an entire
statue of isaiah bradley in there
i'm assuming he did it at night time he
probably got permission from someone who
worked at the museum i would hope so but
i i liked the i like to think that he
snuck it in
you know and they just didn't know she's
like what is the statue doing here what
did this banksy did you put this in here
i think it's a bank seat i think it's a
banksy team i mean but
he thinks he'd be doing some wild
but yes the most thrilling part of the
falcon in the winter soldiers series
finale was the reveal of the new captain
america suit
sported by our newest captain america
sam wilson
and that got us all thinking about this
week's big question how did the
wakandans design this new captain
america suit to build on the
functionality and design
of the past versions eric take it away
yes let's do a suit down
um anything can be a down if you just
talk about it for longer than six
minutes that's that's the whole trick of
the trade
new rockstar yeah uh so yeah we got sam
wilson's new suit revealed in the final
episode of the falcon the winter soldier
and it gives us yet another iteration of
this uniform worn by captain america in
the mcu
we've seen about 10 different looks for
this star-spangled man with the plan up
until this point
but uh this one is really the most
unique as it incorporates a lot of
different elements including
the wings and the jet pack of the x07
armor to honor sam wilson's history as
the falcon
so it's kind of the best of like uh all
three worlds
those three worlds being androids aliens
and wizards that's not a thing that
that's definitely
no it's not and uh we have to remember
that this suit was made by the wakandan
design group
uh and uh despite that though there are
a ton of elements to this new uniform
that paid
homage to the past uh classic look of
captain america over the years
but it's still from wakanda so you know
they had to work in
some vibranium especially in those wings
so let's try to imagine ourselves empty
we're sneaking into
shuri's lab and we're just gonna try to
like put on a white lab coat and uh
blend in with her design team
uh and uh you know see if we can get a
peek at those blueprints so we can piece
together the suit ourselves
a component by component and i think uh
i'm sure nobody would know that you were
there
yeah i might stick out like a sore thumb
sure it could be like
i do not remember you on the science
sheet i'd be like no no no i
i'm an intern no i'll just be like oh no
he's my brother he just has a skin
thing you know just don't worry about it
and she'll look at you and be like
where's your accent
and then we were just like
okay so sam wilson's captain america
suit is one of the most comic accurate
designs we've seen yet in the image hell
yeah
yeah many so nice i love it yeah right
they took it directly out of the pages
of comics more or less uh they're taken
right from the captain america run in
2012 when sam wilson takes up the mantle
of captain america this after steve
steps down from being drained of a super
soldier serum
but one notable difference is how much
more white there is in the design
compared to the comics or really
any previous iteration of captain
america in the mcu uh
this was a very purposeful choice by the
production team
as we learned an interview with michael
crowe that was the lead costume designer
for the falcon the winter soldier
uh since the show deals with a lot of
heavy issues they wanted the new captain
america to be a kind of ray of light in
a finale
and you see that when that shot of him
with the angel wings coming down
oh my god i was just gonna i was about
to bring that up because like it's so
it's seared into my memory just seeing
it obviously like you know this first
new
black captain america just come down
like an angel carrying carly
morgenthau's body i'm like wow
what a holy holy new hero that we have
here
from the heavens i don't know what i'm
saying
uh and michael crow this is his quote he
said there was a lot of discussion about
how much white we were going to use in
that costume when it was being developed
and how much white that color
was going to be versus some of the
previous captain america outfits that
we've sort of toned it down
and it's been more gray than white so
how vibrant we wanted that to be
and i think that tone we wanted to see
at the end of the series definitely told
us
we wanted it to be brighter we wanted it
to be significant and significantly
different than what we had seen before
so really that's kind of a reverse image
a lot of the captain america suit
designs that we've seen in the past
michael has been working on costumes in
the mcu since civil war in 2016. he was
part of those
uh design crews for those previous films
so he has like
been part of the stitching of all this
for the past five or six years
so what other elements did we notice
from previous captain america suit that
the wakandans worked into the designs of
the mcu
so let's start with the colors that
we've seen before obviously there's the
red white and blue
all over the suit it's a staple for
captain america of course you gotta have
it
you gotta have it uh those are all very
vibrant colors especially when compared
to the muted tones of the previous suits
and especially us agent sean walker
possibly evil black suit that he's now
wearing he's got to do the evil stuff in
the shadows and like i can't get caught
see sam can't do that sam is like white
and bright
if sam was jogging in the middle of the
night no car would hit him because he
was playing with scene
but you know john walker is going to do
his uh is twitching in the dark
yeah so you know sam's like the kid who
has to wear the halloween costumes with
like reflector strips on there
i'm not having my a buzz lightyear dress
son
get hit by a car it always already makes
sense it's buzz lightyear he's already
glowing and then the brother is like but
i'm woody why does woody have reflector
scripts
get daddy some candy i mean we do have
captain america playing buzz lightyear
in uh in the light year movie that
pixar's it's true
that's very true yeah this crossover's
already begun
uh but what i love about the comparison
with uh john walker is it really is the
classic western black hat versus white
hat you know
you know they dress the guys in the
black cats who are the bad guys the
dress that you know and
when you call someone black hat versus
white hat now that's what that means but
let's move on to the shield
uh so you really can't have a captain
america suit and not incorporate the
shield uh
it's impossible and the wakandans did
this expertly that shield connects to
the jet pack using similar magnetic
locks that steve rogers would use
to keep the shield firmly on his back is
that what you wanted before it even
happened
yeah it was just like i hope i hope you
can just kind of throw it back there
carelessly and it just as soon as i saw
that i was like eric got what he wanted
[Laughter]
give me those magnets i love magnets
yeah magnets oh
it's like magic but real now we first
saw these magnetic locks put the use in
age of ultron when steven recalled the
shield directly to his arm thanks to
tony's upgrades
you know but sam's suit is the ability
to launch that shield so sam can catch
it in mid-air which is great
another awesome feature that the qrcon
is including the design is the ability
for the shield to connect seamlessly
with the wings creating a full vibranium
bubble
that sam uses to protect that nypd pilot
on the bridge
he made a dome and then like they they
kind of tested it out
in the lab to be like well will it you
know wrap around the dome like how tall
is it they had to find another one
who was as tall as anthony mackie and
test it out and throw helicopters at him
until
until they knew that it was so they knew
there was like okay no
daylight between that shield and the
wings nice
yeah but i love that scene uh that that
moment in the uh
finale is just like oh man that thing is
durable vibranium if it's taking a hit
yeah oh and speaking of vibranium we
don't really get any confirmation as to
which parts of his suit are made of
vibranium but knowing that the wakandans
built the suit we have to assume that
there must be some vibranium all over
that exo7 elements of the suit so the
wings
are likely made of vibranium since they
would need to be as strong as the shield
in order for sam to deflect them that
way
we also see these wings stab into
concrete with ease
so it's safe to assume that they're made
out of vibranium i would say
oh yeah otherwise the what continents
will be pretty stingy they're like we're
gonna spend all this time building a
suit
but it's you know we'll give you um
we'll give you a quarters worth of
vibranium in there
it's like yeah we're running out of
vibranium dog i don't know what to say
uh i only have a mountain of it sure
he's just
mcduck swimming through the pool of
vibranium
uh beads right it feels good it feels so
good it's like stress balls it's the
best
right it's just it's good on the skin
now we can also assume that the jet pack
and the red wings
are made of vibranium uh and maybe even
the shirt and pants of the uniform could
be composed of that nano vibranium mesh
similar to the black panther suits but
we just don't know
how much is there yet but we had to talk
about the star on the chest so really
all of captain america suit designs have
that big old star
in the middle of the chest it's iconic
and it certainly was not forgotten here
and good on the wakandans for knowing
that like the star is not really
our image uh but we get that it's
important the americans so
we'll throw it on imagine they just put
like a big old panther out there like
hey take it or leave it all right
yeah uh if you're gonna be using the
vibranium uh every
bit of vibranium belongs to us sorry uh
yeah
we get our stamp on it like i'm sure the
wakandan um
nascar driver has panthers all over it
they're very good they're very good at
it that'd be so like imagine if like
they just put like you know just a bunch
of wall climbing like brands on the
shield like
you're getting the free shields but like
you gotta throw some sponsors on there
like wakandan soap or like i don't know
hydro soak ends up on there too how'd
that get on here
what hydra soup
wakanda oh but also on the suit there's
the horizontal white stripes that
radiate out from the star they're
similar to
these stripes that we saw on the stealth
version of the cap
suit and captain american the winter
soldier but also a callback to the red
horizontal stripes
on sam's previous falcon suit that
spread out kind of like wings did
but then if you move a little bit
further down you get these vertical ab
stripes
um which is what i've been working on in
my fitness journey
just getting just like some natural
action because it shows been horizontal
lines that are just permanently etched
into my gut from having rolls
even when i stand up straight just those
lines are still there and they've been
gradually fading but some days they
they come back and i'm like how do i
just make these vertical lines
they make it look slimmer if they're
vertical not much luck
as of yet a couple weeks left but hey
man i believe in you you got this homie
thanks man okay but on the suit design
there are these vertical red and white
stripes on the abdominal portion there's
a clear nod to a few versions of the
captain america suit that we've seen
before
from the cheesy fabric uso version of
captain america the first avenger
uh during world war ii and then both and
the avengers and avengers
age of ultron suits but even really in
civil war that suit has some washed out
red and white tummy stripes but let's
talk about the cowl so this cowl was a
really tricky thing to figure out from
the team
who built it uh so sam's version of the
captain america suit does not have the
traditional captain america helmet
uh yeah i don't know why sam's cranium
is every bit deserving
of protection as i mean maybe he just he
just likes the way his hair looks he's
like you gotta show it off you know what
i mean
it's like at my age i could be balding
but i'm not so let's check it out
i've got this cut i'm not gonna flatten
this cut are you crazy
i mean like he's a bird themed hero so
he's got to show off the nest you know
that's
the nest on the top just bird's nesting
it is
but yeah it does incorporate the cowl
that we saw on cat back in the first
avengers film he also had kind of a cow
there
this white cowl on sam was actually a
little bit of a pain in the ass on the
production side there is really no
fabric that can just naturally cling to
the face
and maintain its silhouette actually in
the uh
documentary that they had uh come out on
disney plus
the post-production guys talked about
how they had to clean up just the gaps
in the cowl
they do that cool like wipe effect where
they show you like what it was before
versus what it was after you didn't even
notice i wasn't a fan did you
idiot but no it looks super cool like i
wouldn't like i didn't really think
about that but like yeah i don't think
there is a material that would like
stick like that it's one thing that like
comic book movies have always had
trouble with back to the days of the
michael keaton batman you know there's
that solid piece of rubber that did not
move he could not turn his head
and even then like batman begins when
nolan took it over with christian bale
like he really could not move his head
and they had that joke and uh the dark
knight was like you want to be able to
turn your head
i'm sure my backing out of the driveway
easier basically it was a whole
complicated thing just to put the head
piece on a separate
um you know separate piece than the rest
of the body they had to come up with a
whole
like uh collar rig to go around so that
like they would be seamless
but like he could still move his head
around it doesn't make sense in the real
world none of this makes sense
but also the we notice how the thrusters
the
how red wing kind of breaks off to
become a thruster
it is the shape of the letter a just
like you know amir i love that
it's a really good touch i'm like yes
you know what in case i need help
pushing something to look to the left
see an a look to my right see another a
i know i'm doing it for america
so i'm pushing i got another america on
my left america's on my left and i'm
also on america's left
no matter which way i am something to
the left of me will be something
connected to me that's my favorite
dumb easter egg and all these things
he's noticed he's not to the left so
that's an easter egg
uh yeah so let's talk about the x07
falcon suit design elements that they
brought in here so that original x07
falcon suit was actually designed by
stark industries
that's uh what sam was wearing when he
was falcon
um actually in a previous bite-sized
question we came to the conclusion that
there had really only been two versions
of the x07 falcon suit the one that we
saw in the winter soldier that was
ultimately destroyed
and uh the new upgraded suit in the
final scene in age of ultron
and through civil war and an end game
and the falcon the winter soldier
um and we saw how that suit was starting
to show its age as even red wing
was needing constant maintenance and
apparently the stark industry's warranty
had just run out
uh maybe because stark himself had just
kind of faded out you know his warranty
ran out so you know yeah
it happens good luck returning that uh
he was dead when i got him
i just picturing joke trying to throw
tony's corpse into the ocean but it
keeps pulling back at him
right now this is weird it's where my
brain is all over the place
but among these upgrades that the
wakandans gave the x07 elements were
of course the wings as you mentioned
before probably made out of vibranium
so hopefully they won't be so easy to
tear off if you're an enraged super
soldier who gets um
completely bogus redemption at the end
of the series this is a load of
barnacles
[Music]
and only like that specific scenario i
mean
most people won't do it but those types
but every once in a while you're going
to run into a john walker
maybe even john walker himself because
he is just out not in prison at all
doing whatever he wants to do totally
fine just kill the dude totally fine
[Music]
now these wings appear to fold and
retract in a similar fashion to
past falcon suits and they can be used
both offensively and defensively
um but let's also talk about the
propulsion that traditional orange
thruster we saw in the x07 jetpack has
been replaced by a blue colored
propulsion system
which i believe it means if it's blue it
means it's burning hotter
i think it's one thing i learned at some
point in an episode of big question
if it's blue it means it's burning
hotter okay
some people working at boeing are like
this guy's a freaking idiot
i have failed that's just science yes
science if it's blue that means it's
hotter than
because it's usually supposed to be like
yellow and if it's blue that means it's
just different that means it's a new
level yeah i mean you see that with with
super saiyans
goku got the blue hair that's just how
it is it's just science i'm following
you america
that's right you're we're on the same
page
[Laughter]
but either way it could mean sam is
flying faster than ever before
so you know that's pretty cool oh um
it's worth pointing out not a huge deal
but sam finally has full sleeves that go
all the way to his gloves uh i don't
think we've seen that before it's always
been a little short it doesn't doesn't
go all the way down
you know but he's interested because you
know in the past when he's falcon
he'd like to he liked to play some suns
out guns out
but now he's just like you know i got
some sleeves now i got upgraded to
sleeps
it's a big big step up but also i
noticed in that last episode of falcon
weird soldier
that his flame still works underwater
yeah you could see the blue flame
underwater i'm like is that normal is
that
is that so hot it is just vaporizing
that water and
steam it's just it's because it's blue
flame that means it's like
it's waterproof it's waterproof yeah
it's it's
science it's magnets yes yeah and then
coming back to red wings so red wing
already had some big upgrades
that were demonstrated at the beginning
of the falcon the winter soldier that
included some ai enabled voice commands
as we saw in that helicopter rescue sam
didn't have to like
control it from his you know you could
just say like hey you idiot go
rescue that dude i mean like that's uh
really andy that he can just do it voice
activated because he'd probably get into
an accident if he did
yeah yeah yeah you can't you can't
multitask that well when you're trying
to weave through canyon walls
and uh trying to kill you in a mission
that was never really explained
but also among the upgrades they had a
little pulse laser rockets added to red
wing which is new i think it was just
kind of like a machine gun fire before
uh or sniper fire um but we have to
assume that the wakandans kept most of
this tech in place perhaps even improved
it like we do see red wings laser slice
through that flag smasher spider lock
with ease something that bucky
you know had to struggle with a little
bit but then red wing also uses its
grapple to rescue that other helicopter
pilot
perhaps utilizing an updated more
powerful grapple than the one red wing
had
used to snatch a precocious young
spider-man back in civil war
if we remember couldn't have done that
earlier
i hate you but one of the coolest
features this red wing still has
is the ability to split into multiple
drones if you look closely
yeah so we saw sam split red wing into
multiple drones in infinity war during
the battle of wakanda and we see it here
uh in the series when sam stops the
armored card full of grc members
from plummeting to doom sam's able to
push the vehicle to safety with the help
of two red wings
perhaps an odd house iron man used that
drone thrusters with his uh
with his armor and spider-man homecoming
just a fitting tribute to the original
designer of the x07 falcon suit
mr stark who's this dude tony stark
will not be accepted by the return
counter
like i know i said that the a's on the
red wings little mini red wing things on
the side
helping captain america push the truck
up stood for america
but i think that they could just stand
for io because
maybe she's just like you know what i'm
giving you a favor so like these a's are
for i o and just so you remember me
but i hooked you up so yeah put respect
on my name
and if you uh look at the other designs
uh so they form an a
and then like she uh sam with his wings
forms like a y
and then bucky watching it from below
it's like 24 being an oh exactly
if you zoom out even further uh like two
buildings are forming an
m and then there's an e over in a tree
and it all forms mephisto and then
someone tweets
z and i just write in mepista under my
muted words list because i'm tired
of seeing your tweets about that
i'm so sorry eric please just
let it go everybody very poor choice of
words
it's okay everybody talk about the fisto
everyone's jokes
make your jokes i've seen what makes you
cheer
well thank you for that eric and we're
going to continue with our bite size
questions next but first
award from all the beautiful people that
help make big question possible eric
thanks mt well first we want to thank
our friends at candid for sponsoring
this episode so you don't have to be
unhappy with your smile folks thousands
of people have used candid the clear
comfortable removable and practically
invisible aligners
to help straighten their teeth just like
a real customer cameron s
from nashville who used candid to
straighten their teeth ahead of a
wedding
and now cannot stop smiling your
treatment is prescribed and closely
monitored remotely by a licensed
orthodontist so you'd get the same
quality of care you'd get from an
in-office orthodontist from the comfort
and convenience
of your home with candid the same
orthodontist who created your plan is
with you from start to finish
the average candid treatment is just six
months though you'll start seeing
results way before then
and it costs thousands less than
traditional braces
become your best you start straightening
your teeth today
right now you can save 75 on candid
starter kit
go to candid co.com big question and use
the code bigquestion
that's candidco.com big question code
bigquestion
take advantage of this limited time
offer to save 75 off on your starter kit
candidco.com big question code big
question
we also want to thank our friends at
imperfect booths for sponsoring this
episode every year
billions of pounds of food go to waste
because it does not live up to the
strict cosmetic standards of grocery
store as well
and perfect foods is on a mission to
reimagine the grocery store delivery for
a kinder less
wasteful world they deliver sustainable
affordable groceries including produce
quality protein and pantry staples
straight to your door all you have to do
is sign up create your flexible
personalized grocery plan
and then shop online each week and get
affordable and sustainable groceries
delivered directly to your door
with imperfect boots grocery shopping
fits seamlessly into your life and every
week is a tasty adventure
sign up with imperfect foods today to
save time save money
save food from going to waste and right
now imperfect foods it's offering our
listeners
20 off plus free shipping on your first
order
when you go to imperfectboots.com and
use the promo code big question
try in perfect foods now and for a
limited time get 20
off plus free shipping on your first
order go to perfectboots.com and use the
code big question to sign up that's 20
off plus free shipping and
perfectboost.com offer code big question
all right mt uh i want to hear you
answer some bite-sized questions
all right
okay so what's the first bite size
question of the day eric farrow pie 13
from twitter asks
which celestial's head becomes nowhere
in guardians of the galaxy
wow okay well that's a really great
question
and i know a thing or two about
guardians of the galaxy and so
in guardians of the galaxy vol 1 we're
introduced to nowhere a mining colony in
the skull of a former celestial that is
also the home
of the collector everyone's favorite
frosted man
that likes to collect people very rude
person but he's
he lives a life of luxury uh gamora
describes nowhere as the severed head of
an
ancient celestial being but were never
actually given a name of who this being
was in the comics nowhere first appeared
in 2008
in nova volume 4 number eight and the
writers of that comic dan abnet and andy
lanning
were asked about where they came up with
the idea of the decapitated head
and they said the severed celestial head
was i think something that popped out of
andy's mind one day
similarly one morning i said what about
a talking russian dog
and we run these things and develop them
together it's hard to pin down
where exactly they originate which is
really fun i really like that part of
the crazy
creative process like yes to see like
their weird creations on the big screen
in guardians of the galaxy volume one
yeah so much of abnett and landing's
work and that guardian's reboot was
exactly that kind of thing it was just
like well what if you know rocket was
like this what
if groot was like this and that's what
makes it so great and clearly james gunn
ran with that
oh yeah james gunn loves that oh my
god i like people that value weird
i'm gonna make some weird
later comics gave a backstory to nowhere
that involved the dark god
null using a symbiotic sword to
decapitate a celestial at the beginning
of the universe and null would go on to
use this floating head
as a base where he refined his symbiotic
sword into the all-black
necro sword a sword that is actually
used by gore the god butcher
if i'm not that's right christian bale
is gonna be carrying that bad boy around
fighting thor thunder so hey maybe
christian bale's
gore decapitated nowhere in the mcu who
knows
maybe that's how they'll do it yeah
that'd be a cool tie-in if they just
simplify it that way yeah i'll be i
don't know if we're going to see
null in an upcoming project but i feel
like with gore
um coming up in thor 4 it would be more
more more likely to see that uh necro
sword uh yeah
and maybe a uh chopping off of a
celestial head
in uh four four so but yeah we'll have
to wait and see whether or not we see
null in an upcoming project
and all that gets confirmed but yeah
that's
that's nowhere in a nutshell well
answered question empty
and i believe there's been some theory
saying that that skull
might be the brain that ego floated out
of but
james gunn has debunked that theory oh
he has many of our theories over the
years
[Laughter]
yeah it definitely cannot be those two
those are two separate beings
yeah yeah okay another question uh that
i want you to answer mt from
um martin on twitter who asks besides
wonder woman's lasso of truth
are there other enchanted lassos in the
dc universe
oh okay martin that's a really good
question let's talk about lassos let's
talk about last
you want to talk about lasso spark let's
talk about glasses okay because we're
all familiar
with wonder woman's lasso of hestia
better known as the
lasso of truth and it's a 150 foot long
golden weapon made from aphrodite's
magical waist belt
that forces anyone it captures to obey
and speak
the truth but it's not the only
enchanted lasso in the dc universe
one such magical rope is the lasso of
persuasion
used by wonder girl aka donna troy
unlike the lasso of truth the lasso of
persuasion
is made of silver and while it still has
the power to make its captive do as the
wielder compels them
it only works on those with less
willpower than the wielder
and much like the lasso of truth the
last with persuasion is
indestructible which is even though it's
not gold it ain't going to break
it ain't going you're gonna go ain't
gonna break as easy you know what i'm
saying i love it
oh yeah yeah but there also exists the
lasso of lightning
used by cassandra sandsmark when she was
wonder girl uh the lasso of lightning is
a golden lariat created by ares the god
of war
this enchanted lasso is capable of
utilizing electrical currents
by harnessing the power of zeus's
lightning itself
super cool i don't have anything that
can do that so i'm quite jealous
but it can also compel its captives to
experience intense rage depending on how
angry
the wielder of the lasso currently is
which is super
scary but cool but it cannot compel
people to tell the truth but it is also
indestructible which is a great perk for
any lasso but we should also mention um
a
oddly named lasso uh called the lasso of
submission
you could probably get out of your local
uh you know adult themed store
but we won't get into that but like this
lasso submission it came from
um evil lois lane um superwoman from
earth 3 and one of the multiverses
created after flashpoint the last of
submission can force the person it
ensnares to obey commands and even
fall in love which is not cool you
should use a lasso to make someone fall
in love with you
i mean you bind me up in the lasso of uh
of the lasso submission i'm already
gonna fall in love right now
just from the name alone okay okay
oh man if someone used a lot like i i
don't think i would anyone would need to
use this lasso submission on me because
i just love everyone well i'm not that
i'm
not talking about that kind of love
empties oh talking about dirty
stanky oh dirty
some people don't call that love i call
it love i mean that's making love
eric you know i'm saying that because
yeah why would you make something that
it ain't is
exactly can we just say that all dc
lassos are
weirdly based on bondage based off of
the original wonder woman creator who's
admittedly into bondage himself yeah
it's weird how that's still a thing
that has carried on throughout the years
and that's how that's part of it
hey i'm not going to kink shane if
that's your case if you're in the box
hey genie was locked up in aladdin and
he's my favorite character in that movie
so yeah it's totally fine um i don't
know why i disacquated bdsm to you with
the movie aladdin but that's what i did
continue it on um and of course uh
wonder woman eventually obtains this
lasso
and renames it the golden promise
because the lasso submission is a
terrible it's terrible branding and i
don't think that uh
go back to the old name no you bring
that that's a
that is our bad sense questions of the
day and i am
a child for reacting the way i did i'm
sorry
and so now we are going to move on to my
favorite section of every big question
the box of scraps
[Laughter]
stay with us but today's box of scraps
question
is if you were the head of marvel
studios for a day
what film would you green light that has
not been made yet
i love this question because really
anything we pitch
will probably be made at some point yeah
if you want
whatever whether it's you know you want
a certain deadpool sequel or if you want
a blue marvel movie they're going to
make that movie they'll get around to it
eventually for sure
so i'm ah if it were me i would uh
go back to a movie and just like um
do uh make another movie that would
never get made and pour 300 million
dollars into it
i want them to uh redo
like not do a canonically rewrite of end
game because i love in game but i want
to see like an
end game 1.5 story where it's just like
every other failed time heist mission
that they went on that we just didn't
see like i want to see
all these other attempts where they
tried to go back
uh and it was just like two bonkers too
insane
like they go to the collector's vault on
nowhere
because at one point the reality stone
and the power stone were there at the
same time briefly for like half an hour
yeah and then just some madness there
like cosmo the dog chases them around
and fights thor's nuts off or something
crazy
uh i want to see them go back to the
first iron man
uh or go back to the first captain
america and uh jump on the plane with
steve rogers when he's fighting red
skull
and just like uh fumbled the
freaking tesseract around um i want to
see
a fight where like uh different eras of
red skull fight each other as they're
flying through the bifrost
oh my god that was so bonkers man
i'm into it yeah empty and i were
talking about recently how like
we want to see someone use that old uh
the quantum tunnel device and end game
just to like explore the alternate
timelines just
whoa okay
here i go we're going to see like 12 to
different uh one-off stories of
different people trying to go on
so much fun i would love that they'll
never make it they'll never make that
movie
yeah the closest they'll get is what if
for loki which will be great in their
own ways but not this story
oh my god see we're missing out we need
we need a window we need our own windows
to the multiverse so we can watch
yes this beautiful movie that you just
pitched because i'm all about it that's
so so great
what about you mt what's your dream
movie i mean i feel like i have a
zillion dream movies um
i guess i'm just gonna go with the one
that's been in my mind more recently
because i really want to make a weird
world
film um of like eventually i think
because like
a lot of people don't know the property
weird world marvel doesn't really talk
about it
but i remember when i first started
reading comics like around the time
when uh that secret wars of event from
like 2015 came out
um a little bit after that they released
this um battle um
this uh real weird world comic
um it's just basically just it's a wild
like
world where like it's it's fantasy but
like there's
crazy elements like you're slaying a
dragon in a ferrari
with a sword and like just crazy
it's it's crazy stuff from like the
multiverse is just crammed into this
nonsensical world and i think that
there's a really unique opportunity to
potentially do like a maybe like a
a disney ready player one type scenario
because like disney owns
so many different properties yeah
they're on everything now so like they
you could just shove
everything and just be like this is just
weird elements from the multiverse into
this one
weird world and like i'm just picturing
like you know the
the main character of the series that i
read of the weed world uh galetta
the wizard slayer um she is super super
awesome and i was like hey imagine if
she had like luke
luke skywalker's lightsaber and she was
on aladdin's magic carpet
and she was slaying like going to fight
maleficent like just that type of stuff
it's just disney stuff in one world and
just like going
crazy and they can do that considering
that multiverse madness is coming up
and they're introducing the the concept
in the multiverse yeah and
i just i just like weird stuff in
general so like even if they don't go
the disney route like just throw a bunch
of multiverse stuff in one world
and just have a crazy i don't know a
person from our world go there and just
have this adventure i think it'd be
really cool
yeah i would love to see that movie that
sounds amazing
uh let's both become heads of marvel
studio at some point and
you know what um we're gonna do it you
know we'll just kevin feige will respond
to our letters one of these days you
know
one of these days he's ha he has to or
we will steal his hats
exactly uh we'll take her hats ransom
but that is it for this episode of big
question i want to thank eric
for joining me this episode it is always
awesome talking to you you are literally
one of the best people ever um on this
planet so
thank you um you can follow him at ea
vos because
he is on the twitters and everywhere
else because he's just amazing he just
tweets
and just posts cool things you can
follow me at mastertainment but
more importantly you can follow new
rockstars wherever we are on the
internet especially
on youtube make sure to click that
notification bell to get
all of our notifications because it is
very important because we post some
really great stuff so
don't miss out and also don't forget to
go to our newrockstarsmerch.com
um to buy all our cool merch because we
have the best shirts
ever look eric's wearing his i am eric
voss shirt right now and you get one of
them
i'm going to be hilarious it wouldn't
make any sense
it wouldn't make any sense but i would
love to wear it i just couldn't wear it
to sleep and be like yes you're with me
eric
so we can be that's really creepy i'm so
sorry i said that anyway that's not true
um
anyway thank you guys so much for
watching and stay safe everybody
[Music]
you